catalytic converter theft in the valley
put the bite on one of America's most
famous hot dogs overnight those driving
the 27-foot long Oscar Meyer
Wienermobile say it was stolen in a
hotel parking lot not too far from
Flamingo and Paradise Ryan mathey gets
into the messy details
the Oscar Meyer Wienermobile was just
looking to catch up with Las Vegas this
weekend but what was once cooking
underneath it was stolen joining an
already stuffed problem in the valley it
was here overnight that those driving
the 27-foot long meal on Wheels woke up
to some stalled buns
the hot dog was right here yeah we're
exact right here Bensky off Hacienda and
Decatur towed it here imagine like a
huge gigantic hot dog in the middle of
your Bay Bart's administrator Joseph
Rodriguez says Not only was the
catalytic converter stolen but so was
everything leading up to it there's like
gaskets there that you you need to
reseal the uh the converter and then
there's sensors all along that area to
regulate the heat and temperature of the
system those are all gone as well they
paired that apart to get to what they
want the car park containing precious
metals used to filter out harmful
exhaust emissions into safe gases sawed
off and illegally sold for thousands
they literally just saw it off yeah take
it yeah yep absolutely a growing problem
Nationwide in Las Vegas metro police
reporting over 2 600 deaths in 2022
State Farm reporting over 43 000 thefts
nationally through July 2021 to June
2022.
though these buns now have a temporary
converter that can get it to
pre-superable appearances The Taste
lasts only so long they did like a
little minor repairs basically had the
vehicle running it's not the correct
part it's just something temporarily
it's costing the the person money and
then the company and then just time
now he added that getting new catalytic
converters is sometimes on a four month
back order Metro Police say it has not
yet received a theft report but the
hotel where it was stolen from says its
corporate division is actively
investigating